buddy this is where all our years of  friendship come into play ok this is the  don't shoot the messenger portion of the  show they must withdraw yeah I could  definitely be better I mean I just  basically found out on the show that the  rules can be broken and obviously  because she's not physically here even  if she's able or not then we get voted  off I mean not voted off it's bowed out  basically from the show so I found out  during the show so that was a there was  a little heart wrenching the producers  tried everything they could to try to  keep us in the competition and they knew  I think they worked extra hard because  they knew how much this meant to me as  well and but unfortunately uh you know  the rules are the rules and I don't want  to take somebody else's spot I'm hoping  that they're like the audience kind of  tweets or instagrams it says we want  them back and maybe that all persuade  them